we've been teasing our mystery guests
identity
all week long and we're so excited to
finally reveal
who they are have mercy
it's john stamos i do
what what what devil what did you sell
your soul to
what is in the water what is in the
greek jeans
how do you just not age
i drink roblo's blood first by the way
totally i was like i was at roblo's
birthday party
um when i was like 10 years old and i
had my first slow dance with emilio
estevez
oh me too that's weird
well actually yeah i am
i i gotta have to fan girl out here i am
your biggest fan
i know we don't know each other we
haven't worked we say hi but i just love
you and i'm just uh
so grateful to be on the show and i'm
just such a huge fan of yours
and i'm um i saw that you're having a
choice that they better ask me to be on
there so i'm really glad you did thank
you
i actually think we stalked you but i'm
glad to know
that we won't be in trouble for it i
have been such a fan of yours
my whole life and i actually realized
that you went on general hospital in
1982 is that right
that's right e.t came out in 1982
so 1982 was a good year for us
you know i have to tell you my son i
have a three-year-old son and i know
you have two daughters right the he
loves e.t
he loves et and i told him and he's
about four times he comes
have you talked to gertie where's gertie
where's gertie and he has this book
that gertie narrates and he was
screaming the other day and i said what
are you doing why are you screaming
and he says i'm a really good screamer
and it was from you from that the little
book
oh my gosh i remember making that book
it came with the little album and the
booklet remember those
yes yes that's like from our era how did
he even
find that on ebay i thought yeah it was
old i think maybe his grandfather gave
it to him or something but it was so
it's so cool and you named your son
billy after your father
bill right that's right yeah what a what
a great tribute
i loved my dad he was my hero you know
when you
you know when you you have that moment
where you look at your parent you go oh
they're they're they're just you know
human they're they're not the superhero
i never had that with my dad he was
always a superhero to me he was a
great great man yeah no i definitely did
not have that with my father but
um i was more like oh shoeless hippie
with no job
unaccountable and doesn't live anywhere
perfect um
but you know what i do attribute my
bohemian ways to him and
everything i had a problem about when i
would see him occasionally he'd say oh
you got to kick the bag baby as if what
does
that mean like don't carry it with you
oh yeah yeah yeah kick the bag baby i
was like
said the guy who's an unaccountable
father fine whatever
but i i still i love him he gave me so
many things i have such a like healthy
dynamic with both my parents like
and i i just i loved reading about
your dad and one of the stories that
really stuck out to me was that
he had you still flipping burgers at his
restaurant
the first year you were in general
hospital
you know my parents really didn't give
me a a blueprint for
for much in the parenting department but
they gave me plenty of blueprints for
personality and creativity and artistry
and all these other spiritual
soulful aspects pick the bag and just
move on you gotta kick the bag
baby baby i think your son is in such
good hands and i just
i love the way that you guys model love
yeah we try it's not always easy as you
know i mean don't you wish they taught
some of this in school instead of all
the crappy math stuff you had to learn
i completely agree i'm not dissecting a
ton of frogs but i am
desperately trying to get life right
please
talk to me about the grand scheme
snatching sinatra we love highlighting
podcasts which have taken over the world
yeah i just
you throw a stick out my front door i
hit six people with a podcast
we have a segment that's in honor of the
new frontier it's called the download
okay so what you said was right it's
like the most unbelievable story that
has never really been told
partly because frank sinatra senior
didn't want it told for many many years
this guy named barry keenan um in in uh
he was he was 20 years old and he was at
the
the lowest you know place anyone could
be at life in life and he was parked in
his car overlooking catalina island
and uh god's voice came over the radio
and said
to get out of your issues you know he
owed money his own money was parents he
he was in a lot of debt and a lot of
trouble you need to kidnap somebody
and and the radio wasn't even on he says
so he he he's a very intelligent man
he's still around he's 81 he just turned
81 he
celebrated his birthday here at my house
i think you realize that
this man had mental issues and
you know in the 40s and 50s they swept
that under the table you know mental
illness
so it shines a light on that i mean the
story is so
layered and it's so beautifully produced
having you know
getting the privilege to listen to a lot
of podcasts i just love the mix and the
sound effects and your voice is
perfect and the story is exactly
the story is so compelling and
what ends up happening to him and that
he goes to jail but then he gets out
early because of the claim
of mental illness i think this is just a
very compelling tale i can't believe
it's a true story and
do you have the rights to this yes yeah
to him and you know we're doing some
other stuff with the uh you know
television stuff i was going to say this
is like a tv
show content movie there's so much here
it's so but it's and it's so layered and
you you spoke
he got out he was sentenced to life plus
75 years him and the
two of the other guys that did it with
him but he did get out early
and he then spent 50 years
uh avoiding um you know being shot at by
frank sinatra's senior
i mean he talks about two or three of
the hits the last one so
it went for 50 years sinatra was so old
on his deathbed
and then but the hitman was so old the
last time that he was shot at
the guy the hitman had his uh had him in
the in the sights
and his colostomy bag broke and he went
all over the eddy
that's how long and the story's right
you know i always say it's like the marx
brothers meets the coen brothers how's
that feel
but the podcast being able to do it over
10 episodes has really
let us really get into his psyche and
really understand why a man
would do something this desperate well i
think this
is the cliche of you cannot make this
stuff up
it is riveting you found a story that is
so historically
entrenched with a rich tapestry and yet
it's untapped people don't know about it
so bravo for bringing it to the
forefront i think there's
a lot to continue with this yes
you're right well i
i i'm just so happy to have an excuse
and a reason because i don't know how
we've been around since 82 and not
like hung out and known each other but
i'm it's never too late and i'm just
really happy to make your acquaintance
as someone who's been cheering you on my
whole life
well back at you i i i've been inspired
by you i've just watched you
you know be a kid star then you overcome
issues that you had to overcome and then
you come out you know most people don't
make it past that and you
you know you did i'm so glad and i'm so
glad you share your story with everybody
obviously because it really has helped a
lot of people flower power all that
stuff i say we kick the bag right now
and just you know be
friends well as long as you're here and
putting your magic out into the world
time and time again you have big shot
that everybody loves
david e kelly is just so genius and
everybody i mean
longevity you just you
keep bringing your goods to the world so
please keep doing it and it's about
gratitude right
yes gratitude gratitude gratitude maybe
that's the key to longevity like
being appreciative and recognizing how
lucky we are and and
all the things that your dad taught you
that i found out
along the way luckily i think it is i
think it's part of it certainly
because if you could and it's not just
about the big things like i'm just
grateful
i'm certainly grateful to be talking to
you i'm grateful for the weather today
i'm grateful for my son
you know uh not coughing in my face all
night
do you have to should i try to see him
come up here because oh sure
billy hey bill come in look what i'm
talking to birdie
come here come here you see it wait
come here you see her where is she wait
let's see we do the
speak talk ready hi billy how are you
it's gertie
i look a little different not that much
here come sit
can you see do you know what i love most
about e.t
what he taught me to be kind
and he taught me that being gentle and
good to each other
is really everything i think he learned
that for me t didn't you bill
and he also learned from me too how to
scream well from gertie really
billy do you know how to scream you know
what i'm just gonna do one for you ready
one two three
did you hear that we have a um
can you do it
this is the quietest he's ever been
since since he was in his mommy's tummy
um the we you know i have one of these
these rubber figures from the ride at
universal studios because i collect
stuff like that and we can't find it
right bill every morning goes
dad you find the e.t figurine well
i i i'm so glad that you like
e.t billy it's funny my own daughters
uh they've seen some what they call mom
movies
and yet they're they're they haven't
really connected with e.t yet for some
reason
so thank you billy because my own kids
are not that interested in it funny
enough he hates
anything that i've been on i mean if you
know for oh you want to come come here
and say goodbye
come on consider my life billy do you
ever watch your dad on tv
and like see dad dad movies and dad tv
did you like you like watching me on tv
no
it later like later they start to
appreciate it i think but i'm glad you
like e.t and i like you very much and i
really like your father
and your grandfather who you're named
after and it is just a pleasure to be
with the stamos gentlemen
say bye-bye bill stick something you
know what we made outside and you know
what are you cooking
tomatoes and are you picking tomatoes
in the garden well happy tomato picking
billy
i hope they taste delicious and thank
you drew
hold on okay
bye-bye bye billy oh
no oh he's so beautiful
what a beautiful soul and eyes and kind
and oh thank you i'm really glad to meet
him
thanks for saying hi to him i'm sorry
that he called you gertie but i'm sure
when i meet your kids they'll call me
uncle jesse and then we'll be even
by the way i am gertie and darn proud of
it
so thank you john stamos
i'm so excited to make your acquaintance
finally and let it not be the last time
you or everything that i would hoped and
ex and and thought you would be but more
right back at you and i love this new
podcast the grand scheme
snatching sinatra is out july 12th on
laundry plus
and on july 27th on all major podcast
platforms
this is gonna be a huge hit you really
did on earth
a legendary story wrapped in
amazing history and i think everyone's
gonna freak out over it
thank you thank you very much and i hope
i see you soon
i hope so too in person hopefully too
thank you
thank you